hi we're the try guys and these are our
favorite snacks
[Music]
all right keith you're up first what
have we got one of my favorite snacks is
a specific experience snack it's the
long grocery trip snack and at the end
bring it just bring them in while i'm
talking don't even worry about it
yeah yeah you can have a hard day of
grocery shopping
for yourself for that car ride home you
get some potato wedges wow fried chicken
counter okay we got some ranch where is
that valley i love when you keep the
potato wedges in the plastic for a
really long time the condensation makes
them just so wonderfully moist you know
what you want here's the thing this is a
snack at the time you have to eat it
immediately it's so good i don't think
i've ever had this
i want to watch you eat this what's the
seasoning on here who knows it's the
grocery store recipe and all the grocery
stores
oh
don't listen to him he doesn't know this
guy it's a little mealy if anyone works
at a supermarket
sliding my dms always open for you baby
and let me know
let me know what this seasoning is
because it's magical i'm up next let's
take this all the way to scandinavia
it's swedish fish swedish fish are near
and dear to my heart at my grandparents
house growing up there was like a little
little soda fountain a little corner
store and they had all sorts of candy
and they had swedish fish for one scent
i like these and i always want to love
them but no food gets more stuck in your
teeth than swedish fish so good as chewy
as sweet i used to like these
yeah and i discovered sour patch kids
wow i'm like i ain't [ __ ] with these
people zapats are too intense for me
what yeah they're kids i know but it's
just too much now i don't know what
makes them swedish are they from sweden
it's just a whole truckload of salmon
swimming upstream into my mouth and i'm
a bear
[Laughter]
wow all right i'm up next we're doing
sour patch not just any sour patch sour
patch peaches
yeah baby this is the newest in sour
patch technology okay
peachos right
maybe the best candy ever existed not
anymore because now sour patch is in the
biz i'm very curious i don't typically
love artificial peach flavors yeah no no
this [ __ ] so hard am i allowed to say
that
wow yeah that [ __ ] wow it doesn't smell
like peach
it was probably the best peach oh
experience i've had and it's less pretty
good talk about that texture
it just integrates better than the
swedish fish version that's pretty good
sour pasta knows what is up
sorry zach it's cheez-its little cheese
squares cheese crackers oh those are
great not to be confused with cheese
nips which has always been too salacious
of a snack in my opinion no one wants to
eat a big old bowl of nips speak for
yourself but cheese hits i think have
the it factor they are really delicious
you're lactose intolerant but you're
still down with the cheesies
there's not enough going on in here to
really [ __ ] up my guts
that is i think one of the best features
of the cheez-it is the whiff factor
yeah and the thing about cheese and
sauce smells like cheese they should get
rid of every other flavor they've made
original they all
pale in comparison
i don't care for them they're so good
you don't like these it's cheese
ah i'm up next boys and my favorite
snack what
i love next
that's right um
doritos
doritos are such a good snack they are
scientifically engineered to be perfect
do people know about this it's like kind
of evil do you know of this concept
called the bliss point
well scientists took a whole bunch of
different types of doritos of different
crunchiness levels different uh
dustiness levels different curves
different everything and they mapped it
all out on a multi-dimensional grid and
then found the exact peak where everyone
said
oh yeah
that's perfect and they call it the
bliss point
now you're a nacho cheese over a cool
ranch boy yes
yeah
yeah yeah good spell club
feel good this is one of the most
valuable currencies on the elementary
school playground
you had a bag of doritos in your lunch
you could you rule the world ultimate
power whatever you want is yours yeah
chaos reigns these are like good bags
too this bag's like fresh
girl scout cookies
toss them over here we're gonna open all
these boxes so we have to take them home
i'm ready
oh chess trap wow wow
everyone has their opinion of the best
girl scout cookie but unless it's the
purple box you're wrong i love samoas
this is my favorite cookie it's the
coconut it's the gooey caramel it's the
chocolate now what i do i pop this bad
boy in the freezer oh yeah
and i'm not talking fridge i'm talking
freezer i want them hard as a rock break
your teeth and then what i do we'll
treat what do you do one a day that's it
that's it one and you say vitamin you
say zach you can't have it yeah
it's this is my vitamin and i put them
in the freezer and i i parse it out and
i just feel it out you know it's not
every day but when i need it i have it
and i somehow always make it last right
until the next girl scout season wow do
you guys think that girl scout season
happens like three times a year and we
just don't realize it i feel like it
happens more often than once yeah i
couldn't tell you when it is i don't
know guys i mean people say child labor
is wrong but you brought us this all
right zach's got a bonus one you ready
for this virginia diner dill pickle nut
what the [ __ ] it again yeah these are
dill pickle flavored peanuts
that's weird that can't be good guess
what i was on drugs i tried these
they're delicious
they were really confusing especially
when you really hiked you're like are
these normal peanuts and i just don't
know what flavors are anymore
it's so confusing and then you're like i
don't think i
oh no i do i love these these are the
best things i've ever had yeah i have
one on that exact journey
i was like no no no wait
yes
[Music]
now it's time to promote things that
we're doing we have a new food network
show coming out on august 31st which is
wednesday night coming up soon so make
sure you check it out also just check
out the tri guys channel on youtube
we're doing all sorts of cool stuff
there ned's got a cookbook zach has a
tea i got some hot sauce go buy our
stuff did you say what the show was and
what channel it was on or no i said when
it came out
they'll find it after seeing this video
they're gonna be like i gotta see more
of these guys
[Music]